unsane was directed by steven soderbergh
and stars Claire Foy s Sawyer a young
woman admitted to a mental institution
against her will while she's there we
learned a little more about her past and
that past creeps into that institution
and causes some very traumatic things
for her and no gratefully this is not a
remake of Dario Argento's film as you've
likely heard from every review or
article published about this film
Soderbergh shot the whole thing with an
iPhone 7 plus utilizing the filmic Pro
app and three moment lenses 18
millimeters 60 millimeter and a fisheye
Soderbergh even went as far as to state
he thinks most audience members won't
notice and that this is the future of
movies let's just stow that debate for a
second and focus on the story Claire Foy
is captivating she's excellent in all 97
minutes of this movie she really adds a
lot to this film and as we begin to
uncover and unravel her past and
understand how it connects to her
current predicament the film gets pretty
engrossing whenever it involves her
character and the hardship she's dealing
with also great is Joshua Leonard as an
orderly at the institution who has
sinister motives of the three stars of
the original Blair Witch Project he's
had the most success however he's been
relegated to mostly horror b-movie so
it's nice to see him given a meaty role
with some substance like most films
about mental institutions especially
ones with unwilling patients this film
does have a lot of frustration when it
comes to Sawyer never being heard she's
constantly shut down by the other
orderlies and patients and Soderbergh
tries to create a sense of uncertainty
when it comes to her sanity even the
film's marketing campaign says is she or
isn't she but at least for me this
mystery didn't seem all that confusing
and what eventually unravels felt more
like a natural progression than a
fascinating turn of events Sawyer's
mistreatment and the actions of everyone
around her point to one possible outcome
so the film rarely surprised me Sawyer's
interactions with the other patients and
the orderlies mostly ended the same with
some form of violence
slap a punch some kind of act of
aggression that only makes her look more
insane and it got kind of irritating
after a while because she would make
choices like that that didn't make sense
for someone who does have a good head on
their shoulders it was like watching
someone try to climb out of a hole while
simultaneously digging the hole deeper
so let's talk about that cinematography
because it's pretty much impossible to
avoid when a filmmaker in Soda Berg's
position makes a choice like this I look
for logical reasons why if you're a no
budget filmmaker the decision to use an
iPhone makes sense but what about this
film needed it the best that this choice
does for this movie the story not
necessarily the production but the story
is create a sense of schlocky cheapness
almost documentary esque it makes some
of the events that Sawyer has to endure
a little more frightening because it
feels slightly more personal but soda
Berg's claim that no one will notice is
ludicrous the 156
aspect ratio the overblown highlights in
the color spectrum and even the jittery
dolly shots are noticeable to anyone
who's ever made a short film before the
images are mostly flat with little depth
coming off more like high-quality
security camera footage than something
cinematic there's no doubt that
Soderbergh is a phenomenal director but
when you are a director in his position
a choice like this seems more like a way
to get excited again about making movies
and less of a technical option that
actually benefits the film Soderbergh
has been very upfront in the past about
the fact that he wanted to quit they
came back and he made Logan lucky which
was entertaining and now this so he's
back again but it does kind of seem like
he's searching for a way to revitalize
himself and get more excited about
filmmaking this option didn't really
work necessarily to make the film any
better but still this film I think is
recommendable purely because there is a
fairly palpable sense of paranoia
generated especially because of Clare
Foy's brilliant work so at the very
least I can say check the film out for
those things it's not going to change
the way films are made as sort of her
perhaps thanks
but it's an interesting movie like even
when Soderbergh doesn't make a great
film that's not very remarkable he's
always an engaging director there's
always something to talk about
I'm gonna give unsane a b-minus guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more reviews very soon
you're the best and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]